tha
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir je suis très heureux de vous
présenter pour la première fois ce soir
le nouveau jeu darmangeat mots des
chiffres et des lettres
comme tel constat c'est ce jeu est très
simple et je vais pas vous ennuyer trop
longtemps avec des explications un peu
fastidieuse en fait qu'il reprend le
principe du mot le plus long que
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent et ils
retrouveront j'espère avec plaisir mais
dans cette émission en mangea mots
associés au mot le plus long à nouveau
jeu de chiffres nous appellerons le
compte est bon et qui va nous permettre
de faire les opérations de calcul mental
d'ailleurs je vais pas vous donner de
plus longues explications vous allez
découvrir ce jeu en jouant avec nous
qu'avec surtout avec nos candidats quant
à dire qu'ils ont fait le plaisir de
bien vouloir et d'augurer ce jeu et qui
est bien entendu maintenant on
connaissent parfaitement les règles je
vous présente d'abord à ma droite madame
coux bonsoir madame coxeurs donnez nous
quelques quelques petits renseignements
sur vous pour la première fois que vous
êtes mariée et mère de famille petite
fille qui s'appelle comment alexandra je
pense qu'elle n'a pas encore comprendre
que nous sommes en train de faire
l'instance partir ou rester pendant dix
semaines peut-être que non haletant et
de l'autre côté monsieur pension au jour
monsieur bonjour vous vous êtes mariés
aussi marié oui quel est votre
profession représentant représentés ce
que je voudrais disposal aux lettres ou
aux calculs plutôt beaucoup plus aux
calculs quand même bien eh bien nous
allons voir si vos prédictions se
réalisent
je vous précise enfin pour mémoire que
le mot le plus long consiste à face on
se conseille de la façon suivante c'est
à dire je vais tirait cette lettre
voyelles et consonnes que vont leur
communiqué les candidats et avec que ces
lettres ils devront fabriquer le mot le
plus long possible mais ici intervient
notre ami max favalelli qui a le
redoutable honneur de contrôler la
valeur et l'orthographe des mots qui lui
sont proposés par sony va d'ailleurs
ouvrir lui-même quels sont les mots qui
sont acceptés ou l'amant qui sont aux
fruits alors voici notre code sont admis
à tous les genres masculin féminin
singulier au pluriel tous les maux sable
composé figurant dans un dictionnaire
scolaire d'usagé courant dans son
édition la plus récente ainsi que les
verbe à l'infinitif et les partis passer
accordé alors que vous sont refusés les
moines une lettre les interjections d
noma taupe et pur les préfixes des
abréviations les sigles des symboles
chimique des locutions latines élocution
étrangère même usuelles dans le langage
courant et enfin les noms propres de
lieux ou de personnes merci maps ovalie
nous sommes donc tout à fait au courant
je croise la façon dont à dérouler le
jeu sorte d'accord monsieur penser aux
lames course bien il ne reste plus qu'à
tirer au sort je pense que je peux me
permettre de demander à mme labrousse de
choisir la première
phase
et bien c'est pile et c'est monsieur
pense you qui va commencer tout de suite
à jouer avec nous au mot le plus les
passions je vous écoute consonne voyelle
voyez excusez-moi
voyelles riel
consonne voyelle
voyelles voyelles
voyelles
voyage
à connaître
c'est que 15 secondes
top 4 m quatre lettres madame cox pas
mieux jouer
jcs
au
i e donc ce soit un bon présage pour
vous monsieur pensionnaires vous
marquent elles ont quatre points
et immédiatement nous allons passer
au compte est bon avec notre charmante
hôtesse marie noëlle qui a devant elle
quatre rangées de plaques six plaques
sur lesquels sont marquées des chiffres
c'est des nombres et je vais vous
demander de lui indiquer ce que vous
choisissez
première rangée
2e
4e
3e
2e
première
et bien voici donc 50
2-10 oui voila j'aimerais vous
précisément vous êtes speedomètre
quelques explications de plus avec ses
six chiffres vous allez devoir effectuer
des opérations de calcul mental simple
c'est-à-dire additions soustractions
division et de réplication pour
retrouver très exactement où vous
approcher le plus possible du nombre qui
veulent apparaître que marie noëlle
vianne tirait qui est 8 199 précise
enfin que vous l'avez le droit d'envoyer
les chiffres qu'une seule fois chacun
maintenant je crois que tout est prêt et
pour une minute à l'autre
plus que 15 secondes
top top je continue jusqu'à la fin de la
minute
tottenham et je profite donc de ce tour
de wayne crookes vous préciser un point
de règlement madame coux à trouvait le
chiffre exact avant la fin 2008 elle a
donc dû top maintenant il va falloir
qu'elle nous explique très exactement la
façon dont elle a trouvé 899 et pour
cela il ya un monsieur qui sera très
important qui soufflait un peu l'alter
ego de l'aps au valais leaké monsieur
fabien vu l'air mais ce calcul qui va
vérifier les calculs que va nous
annoncer maintenant madame couflens coux
très clairement s'il vous plaît
50 oui madame que multiplie 10 +8 très
doucement six puis dix plus suite c'est
à dire 9 109 100 oui au hasard - 1
899 c'est exactement dames le compte est
bon le compte est bon dans la course ou
marquer donc six points c'est un très
bon départ pour vous le score à l'heure
actuelle de 6 à 4
voyelles voyelles et consonnes
et voyelles voyelles
voyelles voyaient
leur a fallu qu'on sonne consonnes et
loyal et voyelles club que la m
quinze secondes
top monsieur boucher km
2 2 mais c'est là toi comme si vous êtes
vous d u
d e max à valérie et bien oui on pouvait
faire que ça je crois et lot de
candidats de candidats indispensable au
bon déroulement du jeu bien entendu
monsieur est rare toujours pour la
cinquième fois dans notre jeu on n'en
dira pas plus vous êtes toujours en
forme ça va ça va alors un peu nerveux
au début d'un jeu dans toujours toujours
chaque fois je pensais pas autant que
d'habitude
votre adversaire aujourd'hui est un très
jeune candidat qui à 18 ans je crois les
sept districts qui s'appelle monsieur
brome nc saint romain et qui descendance
engagement l'origine c'est pratiquement
un match international quel est votre je
vous dis par votre profession de
qu'est-ce que vous faites aussi je suis
en mathématiques supérieures a donc un
bon point les jeunes là c'est peut-être
où je ne sais pas je savais pas
une mathématique sont loin du calcul
mental et âme ce qu'on gagne il faut
vous décontracter le plus possible
essayez la forte partie faire affaire
forte partie et je bien je vais vous
demander tout de suite de choisir pile
ou face pile oui
eh bien c'est pile les messieurs promet
d' c'est à vous de commencer avec le mot
le plus long pont sommes consacrées aux
voyelles
voyelles et consonnes essonne
voyelles voyelles et consonnes
consonne voyelle
voyelles et consonnes encore et qu'on
sonne
car secondes
mais c'est comme un conte bien-être 5 7
5 une femme arabe à air arabia a r ah
mais c'est accepter max cet axe-là n'y
avait pas lieu je vais shaoshi mais
peut-être qu'à mieux ça s'imposait
et quel dommage j'ai essayé de détruire
la montagne mais l'amour thème là-bas il
faut dire beaucoup plus près en tout cas
que ce soit les pays communistes erreur
oui non c'est
pas moi c'est très bien
oui j'aurais dû être comme ça matches
nuls auraient gravé là
alors que chabrol a droit à a le moment
tenta dans cette édition de la raison
profonde de ma préventif voilà le con
la plus petite boîte mais non pas la
moins bonne et le beau le plus long plus
puisque c'est la nouvelle année un
chocolat ou auquel jouent à merci je
vois cette fois-ci oui oui cette fois là
oui mais moi non non non j'en ai sinon
c'est comme ça un boulier et le prix
emmanuel gaulier chabrol il manque très
flatté vous pourrez le porter lors des
réceptions à l'elysée voilà où ils ont
tout de suite le prix les mâles régulier
voilà
sur cette image merveilleux de la
nouvelle année grands metteurs en scène
français claude chabrol qui n'a pas
hésité pour les chiffres et lettres là
se mettre à boulleville d'occasion qui
reçoivent l union de murs le
shaq faisant sixième victoire ne m'en
parlez pas je ne sais pas jusqu'où vous
allez aller comme ça ça sera bien
s'arrêter un jour vu le première j'avais
nekili jeu messi souffre et
espérons que notre votre prochain
adversaire ne vous mènera pas en bateau
oui c'est oui oui bon acheter
voilà bonsoir à tous merci et la
prochaine fois et bonne année 1 les
chiffres monsieur voit la première
première première 1ère 3e première
10 à
25 9 3 et 6
[Musique]
sur la 597 monsieur karikari béret même
chose alors 25 - 24 24 oui
ne fait 6 15 et 10 25 oui x 24 600 600 -
3 - 3
solution je laisse mon petit bout de
papier neuf fois
6,54 +3 57 x 10
577 25 595
vingt quatre fois bien dans plateforme
quatre points 28 à 10
et la sonnerie finale
ce cas ribéry dans une carie qui ribéry
dans une position assez défavorable pour
le moment 28 à 10 ce sera relativement
difficile vous commencerez la prochaine
fois avec les lettres et nous espérons
tous bien sûr que fabien sera aussi
brillant qu'il est ce soir c'est
vraiment remarquable n'est ce pas
monsieur renard te dire
notre colère contre - vraiment vous avez
raison de siffler un peu en colère
contre vous oui messieurs car libéré
carrick et ribéry encore plus voilà une
fenêtre on la prochaine fois tous
ensemble j'essaie de m'exercer d'ici là
je vous souhaite à tous une très bonne
soirée pour ça
champion mais on change de discipline et
chiffres et les lettres antunes nouvelle
championne une institutrice de 36 ans
sont en gilet l'hérault mais l'événement
aussi à monte carlo hier soir c'était
aussi la jolie java de cabrol et la
faune qui ont fait la fermeture d'un
certain nombre d'établissements de nuit
pour accompagner individuellement chez
elle quelques danseuses brésiliennes de
passage sur la côte des documents
attestent star donc je fais a repris du
mans c'est que ce sont des gauches tôt
dans leur famille en arrière ça se fait
un grand grand grand moment d'émotion en
tout cas pour tous les fidèles de
l'émission c'était la gestion des
pouvoirs petit souvenir je vous quitte
et je vais demander à mon successeur que
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur cette
scène à laurent cabrol de bien vouloir
venir nous rejoindre vous la policière
dès demain à 18h45 le jeu continue
l'équipe est toujours la patrie sera
toujours parmi nous nous espérons qu'il
viendra nous voir de temps en temps bon
bah demain 18h45 les chiffres et les
lettres nous serons tous là toute
l'équipe et j'essaierai j'essaierai de
remplacer patrice je sais que ce n'est
pas toujours facile mais soyez
indulgents pendant les premiers jours et
ensuite ça ira beaucoup mieux jouer
simplement un dernier mot très
honnêtement vous fassiez une ovation à
patrice c'est lui qui a porté les
missions pendant des années et je tiens
absolument à une phase innovation et la
bande am consonnes et voyelles et
consonnes est-ce
qu'on sonne
j'y voyais
voyenne eux
consonne
c'est
voyelles
à conseil
n la voyelle
eux
et qu'on sonne elle
avec van damme la fenêtre avec enculage
au pluriel
enculage oui et des mouches
exclusivement
bien entendu
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai un dictionnaire très pudique
qui n'admet pas ce mot mais heureusement
pertes rôle là
[Musique]
bonsoir je demandais aux voilà au public
non pas de nous applaudir mais
d'applaudir antibes juan les pins samedi
mais sa municipalité qui nous a très
gentiment reçu comme chaque année c'est
donc le neuvième tournoi grand tournoi
open des chiffres délecte nous sommes en
direct du palais des congrès d'antibes
juan les pins nous ne sommes pas seuls
le public bien sûr et puis les candidats
c'est très très nombreux ce week-end 90
concurrents exactement se sont affrontés
dimanche pour essayer de gagner leur
qualification à l'issue de des premières
rencontres ce qu'il convient d'appeler
le duplicate
ils se sont retrouvés à 16 pour les
huitièmes et des quarts de finale qu'ils
ont eu lieu hier lundi et aujourd'hui et
bien les quatre demi-finalistes sont là
je vous les présente immédiatement il
s'agit de christian quesada que je vous
demande d'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
jean-françois d'ornans
olivier selon lui
[Applaudissements]
olivier sol qui dans la salle avec
pierre-marie billy qui est l'autre
demi-finaliste
[Applaudissements]
tout près d'eux il est là pour les
chaperonner pour veiller sur notre ami
et producteur bien aimé armand jammot
est avec lui bien sûr que nous savions
que nous applaudissons
alors nous retrouvons donc que olivier
sol et pierre marie bigard jeudi et
vendredi puisqu'ils sont demi-finalistes
on va s'intéresser dès cette première
demi finale qui oppose donc christian
quesada et jean françois normand alors
l'un et l'autre vous n'êtes pas des
inconnus des chiffres et des lettres
loin de là monsieur qui s'adapte d'un
palmarès impressionnant une carte de
visite éloquente allez-y je vous écoute
j'ai eu la chance de remporter le
tournoi de monaco donc la coupe des
champions 87e en tournoi de nîmes en 89
et la coupe des clubs à antibes mois de
juillet dernier dit-il modestement dans
sa peau neuve
monsieur normand bon toi palmarès et
moisé le camp mais votre valeur et
rennes
8 de toute manière tous les concurrents
arrivent en même temps me s'agira des 88
qui étaient là dimanche tous très bons
et très bonne et les quatre finalistes
sont très bons
bonjour
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à antibes
juan les pins pour la 8ème coupe des
clubs et oui le temps passe très vite
toute l'équipe est réunie sur le plateau
vous allez la découvrir yvette plat dit
harlem
[Applaudissements]
berthoin regard et j'ai le très grand
plaisir de vous présenter le petit
nouveau petits nouveaux on peut le dire
parce qu'il a 28 ans donc il est tout
jeune c'est laurent romejko
bonjour la rente mais je vous laisse le
fauteuil qui vous revient merci merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
à antibes pour cette huitième coupe des
clubs des chiffres et des lettres ariel
vous le vous le disait alors ici devant
ce public il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de monde rassemblé dans
cette salle du palais des congrès
d'antibes juan les pins et moi c'est ma
première coupe des clubs c'est aussi ma
première émission alors avant toute
chose je tenais à dresser quelques
remerciements des remerciements tout
d'abord à l'ensemble de l'équipe des
chiffres et des lettres tout
particulièrement élevé de plailly ariel
boulin prat ar lenn bertrand renard et
puis bien entendu armand jammot à merci
également à mon prédécesseur max meynier
qui hier dans cette émission est bien
m'a adressé ses voeux de réussite et je
tiens à le remercier donc voila voila
pour les remerciements cette huitième
coupe des clubs des chiffres et des
lettres se dispute ici à antibes et cite
une tradition puisque la municipalité
d'antibes chaque année accueille cette
émission avec beaucoup de chaleur
beaucoup de sympathie et nous tenons
également à les remercier alors pour
cette 7e coupe des clubs il y a quatre
clubs qui sont en compétition
cette compétition va durer toute la
semaine avec les deux demi-finales la
finale samedi à partir de 16 heures
jusqu'à 17h30 et les clubs qui sont en
compétition cette année sont les clubs
de marseille versailles anthony et laxou
alors ce matin il y eu un tirage au sort
pour désigner les deux clubs qui se
rencontreront pour cette première
demi-finale ces clubs je voulais
présenter tout de suite c'est tout
d'abord le club de mars il est le club
ensuite de versailles club de marseille
que je vous présente
des candidats de ce club de marseille a
tout d'abord à gauche philippe rokia
avec vos applaudissements bien sûr
jean-pierre mandras
et enfin jean philippe chauveau
l'équipe de marseille et et habillez
vous le voyez en bleu marine est juste
derrière ce monsieur est le remplaçant
de l'équipe de versailles c'est hervé
dino mais qui est là pour surveiller un
petit peu ce qui se passe
l'équipe adverse maintenant l'équipe de
versailles avec tout d'abord bertrand
bossert
olivier sol
et enfin assis à gauche on
et puis idem pour l'équipe 2 de
versailles vient c'est le remplaçant de
l'équipe de marseille qui est juste
derrière pour surveiller un peu la
situation c'est gérard viglione
alors en ce début de match une petite
précision contrairement à l'accoutumée
où le dur et la durée de réflexion et de
40 secondes pour chaque coup
exceptionnellement pour cette coupe des
clubs cette durée ne sera que de 30
secondes et c'est l'équipe de marseille
qui va commencer alors je vais demander
à philippe roca de s'approcher du
pupitre et puis pour l'équipe de
versailles s'est assis à gauche on qui
va jouer c'est marseille qui va
commencer à jouer avec harley nos
chiffres
[Musique]